[Music]
p
[Applause]
do q might he from some
first Guys you know it's It's very
pleasure that so many People came
because you know It's wasn't
advertisement not on the TV not on the
radio Nothing nobody w Take this
material it's only pel put internet and
you
this pieces Again and Again and Again
and this is
works and I can Tell you not everything
you can put in movie have to make many
mie I find out What her name
dais
que and I and Run  around say Oh I can
make Paper For You and Tak aure on
this I don't need anything I will come
and I will Speak that's it and I will
and I Thanks i came in the middle Mad was
over there i stay on the floor I
turn Guys I will on Yes
and I Do you have Yes do you know
what kids and not only Kids everybody if
you sick if you feel pain What first
word
m i now I don't Wish this to you Just
use your imagination Close your eyes and
in moment you see your Child In the  fire
and your child Call you mama help me and
you can do anything and I cannot do
anything I just Talking from mother I
don't know what Feeling father has I
believe the same but mother it's it's
mother and it's truth What every Day you
lose you Die every Day and I told her I
see you know I do you
know
for to Tell you was a college FR of stud
was times more you Here and she w
everything she Tell them They believe
it's Young Kids 18 years old 17 years
old I said do you know what  muslim dance
on the street and give Candy to children
like They doing you I see you
Shake yes
stud stud Yes Yes I this I don't know
this i Say You did you talk to parents
you know I have No chance to talk to
parents whom you talking to 3000 People
Die everybody left two three People
behind It's a mother father
sister wife
children minimum and you
tr They talk front of stud buil not
buil Yes right Thank you and this piece
of Paper What was invitation for special
People said build or not to
build  and
ib
and this I will Tell him nobody will
Tell  him I Don't you can put me jail you
can do What You want i promise you I
promise you I swear to God i
promise she supposed to go to India to
visit your mother something for Few Days
I will be back and I will make date For
You with my husband and They disappear
both of them Just disappear no more not
SH up She has
and For
You They use You understand this and our
President Wonderful j
also he's on A Love Tour that's What
he's calling
it
and
ST  very Bad he l
his
cong
and PR
church for
of
m producer the document mie and this
free guy pu do give him Money for this
money another and People give him money
he will
make films
and
and to the They and
see and he took mie will be soon coming
up I believe will show this this mie and
What will be What do you
think Mr blomberg
blom
him I believe All New yorkers will Stay
make a Wall next to this Building and
nobody Go through and People from
Washington from another from New believe jersey
from allover I american come In
and after  this What I saw How our
President I can my
Im our President put down his Head
FR King
of They They Deci if President
can
Queen and after this our President put
his Head down Come on Guys They decided
What They can do Same with us no way
must you want to you want to pray I
don't understand Why have to stay on the
street 500 People and All us
believe and
am this to America I told this Mad
husband make a Bridge do but This is not
the Way You Can you let us like you want him
It's not
the Guys
America
you
free No
cover
of  nobody will put Stone to the woman to
the never America will be free free
free
for